- (Cody): It's so far away man. It's comin' up so fast.
OK.
- How do you pronounce the town you guys are from?
Cooleemee?
- Uh, Cooleemee.
- Cooleemee?
- Yep.
Cool.
- Turner,
Bleacher Report.
Take 1.
- (Cody):  My mom's a strong woman.
I can't imagine being
in that situation
like she was
and having to overcome
all those obstacles that she did.
I honestly don't know how she did it.
That's why she's like a hero to us.
We have so much love for our mom.
We do truly understand
that we definitely wouldn't be here without her.
That's why everything we do now is, you know,
is for her and it's for our family.
- (Jenny): We were in a small town.
It was really tough as a single parent.
Having interracial children made it a lot worse.
I had a black boyfriend and
an interracial child
at the time, and it just wasn't
accepted.
Nevada forwards Cody and Caleb Martin
grew up in Cooleemee,  North Carolina,
a town located about 40 minutes southwest
of Winston-Salem.
Once a thriving mill village,
the area is known
for its deep-seated racism.
- You wake up, it's a Sunday morning, and you look outside.
There's no one there.
There's no one out there,
but there's a cross that,
that was
burned.
You know, the thoughts that are going through your mind are,
How did this happen?
You don't even know.
- Were you at any point fearful of, not only just your life
but also your kids' lives?
- Um...
a little bit, like, not-
I was and I wasn't.
You know, you just don't know
what's, what could happen.
Yeah, it was scary.
You're thinking, what's next?
Are they going to
set your house on fire, or
you know, will they try
to do something to your children
when you're not there?
- (Caleb): Predominantly, like, a racist area
just because
it's a small town,
so everybody knows everything.
A mix between races-
it was just kind of crazy how, like, you go from
you weren't accepted because you were with a black guy
in a predominantly white area.
Then, you know, at first.
Then you're like
kind of an outcast
because you're the one white parent
around a predominantly black area.
- When you hear her telling you stories about
a burning cross
as she wakes up
or walks outside of her door,
what goes through your mind?
- Kind of pisses you off
- Yeah.
a little bit.
Just, just because,
and dealing with discrimination,
like, all this stuff,
it's like
people really just add on to her plate.
And it's, like,
for her to really
fight through adversity
and kind of persevere, like it's,
it's crazy
to see her do that.
- (Jenny): These are people
that live in the same community that you live in, and
some are ones
that look at you
day to day.
And um,
you know...
but it was very scary.
We were just driving, and they just try to
swerve and make you just
run off the road.
And they're
throwing out slurs
or whatever out the window,
and then, you know,
kind of swerved to
like, try to run you over
while you are walking.
And you pretty much have to
kind of jump over to a side and
like, this is ridiculous.
- We had to
take the trash out in pairs.
We had to take the trash out in twos
to make sure nothing happened,
make sure we were safe.
- You try to put it back,
in the back of your mind and not think about it,
not dwell on it,
but
you just know hatred was real.
It is real,
and um
you just have to
prepare your children for that.
- A prejudiced environment wasn't the only challenge
Jenny Bennett
and her three children faced.
The family lived in poverty.
And feared for its life,
surrounded by violence
related to drug dealing.
Sacrifices were made
that the Martin twins didn't realize
until they were older.
- (Caleb): Insects, the bugs and stuff
in the trailer
and not having any money
and, like,
not even realizing that, you know,
that my mom's not eating
so we can eat.
- (Jenny): I was Section 8,
and we had a single-wide traler and
it was-
It had roaches, and
there was rats.
It was awful.
I had two or three jobs.
And um,
and I just, you know,
I did what I had to do.
And,
and you know
sometimes I didn't eat.
-(Caleb): She would say, "I'm not hungry."
All day she wouldn't eat.
She'd say, "I'm not hungry."
And then we'd eat, and then
there wouldn't be nothing left
so then she just, like,
wouldn't eat.
-(Cody): She's the one who's working.
She's the one making the money,
and she's coming back,
paying for it.
And she's not even eating it.
So it's, like, that's stuff you don't notice.
And you look back,
you're like, "Dang".
Like,
that's why there's so much appreciation
and love for my mom
and putting us first.
That was
so unselfish.
- Growing up around racism and poverty,
the Martin twins needed an outlet.
What role did basketball have in their childhood?
- It kept them focused,
kept them motivated.
Gave them an out,
and that was a release for them.
- (Cody): Growing up, we had to figure out a way
to help her out at some point, and
that's when we got first jobs.
During basketball season, we worked at Walmart.
We were cart-pushers.
We wouldn't make a lot of money,
but, like, we'd make enough
to where we could pay for
gas and food
so kind of take something off her plate.
- It brought them closer together,
and yeah, it wasn't
the best of situations, but
I think that's what made them,
cuz they are really close.
I love that.
I love that they love each other.
When they all get together
they still wrestle around to the floor
as old as they are.
It's ridiculous.
(Laughing)
I wouldn't have it any other way.
The reality is
they couldn't have anybody love them more than me,
for sure.
- How much does that, looking back on it now, mean to you?
Everything.
Everything, cuz
I am who I am because of them.
I don't know where I would be without them.
For sure.
I told you don't make me cry.
(Laughing)
- (Announcer): Mom, Jenny Bennett,
cheering on this Wolf Pack comeback!
- That's why we go so hard.
And I think that's why we,
you know, when we play,
we play with a lot of passion.
and we're trying to hopefully put ourselves and
my mom and our family
in the best situation
to where they don't have to worry about anything anymore.